this is my day as them are normally
house today we're gonna be trying some
Japanese drunk snacks okay mommy said
that's cute also it says let's party on
it which is something a directive I much
appreciate getting whoo okay alright
okay okay you know I can't trust
anything that's in a package like this
Bobby okay I'm excited now okay what did
the AAA to be what did it say Bobby what
does that mean you know when you said
wasabi flavor I thought I was gonna be
like I was eating wasabi it tastes like
kind of like a pop chip with just like a
hint of the wasabi nose clearing flavor
oh that crunch though they're really
satisfying crunch miss Haysom are gallon
maybe the only Calif I'm good so scallop
flavored it smells pretty similar to the
wasabi one I feel like I'm eating like a
bad version of possibly named Luna I
feel that way too but I like it
definitely
you like everything so these are let's
just take a look at this y'all called
Graz Oh crunch crackers crops so I guess
they're crackers they look like tiny
little corn nuts
honestly this smells like hotdogs like
yeah yeah they smell exactly like
hotdogs
I hope they taste like hotdogs and I got
a nut okay let's do it yes whoa yo we
taste look exactly like hotdogs I would
buy this every day okay this one's
butter and salt flavor I know I'm gonna
love this already now wow this smells
like this this smells like movie-theater
buttered popcorn
you know when they serve you bread for a
meal this is what they should serve try
the last one these are edamame flavor
and I really like edamame oh they're
cute
lucky charms whoa
it tastes like very very salty edamame
I like the edamame in the best flavor
seems a little bit more mild avocado
lava lava avocados are avocado double
double cutters ow
that's a doozy Japanese drunks next
seems pretty buttery seems like I'll buy
Steakhouse bread yo they're really cute
faces though yeah look really scared no
I don't like that it's kind of taste
like wasabi that's gone bad maybe
they're growing different avocados in
Japan maybe we're doing it wrong maybe I
wasn't supposed to taste like that in
which case good job oh wow oh so strong
did you eat this if you were drunk and
if I'm a drunk I eat anything I'd
probably eat cardboards she's good but I
like about it is that you can clearly
taste the cheddar and then it's very
buttery this is like a slightly warmer
times cheese it hey yeah see this what
I'm talking about I ate so much flavor
isn't actually excited about
oh yeah that's like it's like a game
yeah okay that smells awesome
oh that's heavenly let's eat it
yeah that's really good I don't once it
has like seaweed vibes to just just like
the mildness of you go masa you go masa
I want to give somebody this set just
because it looks cool and it's fun for
parties I mean the thing is if you were
having a party this is such a convenient
way to serve snacks just like pop this
down on the table pop it open and then
everyone can just grab something on
their way out and like if there's one
thing drunk people love it's fun and
games oh yeah funny games and toys this
seems like just like a big toy oh yeah
[Applause]
I play beer pong yeah
[Music]